all right as I often say on a bunch of
my videos I'm not a scientist actually I
often bring on people that are much more
well versed in science to clean up some
of the messes that I've made whether
comes to stem cell research Ebola
etcetera etcetera uh but one thing has
come to my attention lately because
we've done a bunch of stories on high
fructose corn syrup in you know corn is
in absolutely everything it is in things
that you cannot believe it's in I highly
recommend you watch the documentary food
and find out what corn is it's in
everything you're not gonna believe it
corn is also by the way in our soda
that's right we use high-fructose corn
syrup in coca-cola the coke people
aren't gonna be happy with me high
fructose corn syrup is basically just a
cheaper way of making sugar right so
they're do now many spoonfuls do you
know how many spoonfuls of this are in
this thing well I googled it because I
have a computer and there are nine and a
half teaspoons of sugar in a can of coke
and I was like you know what I'm not a
scientist but I want to see what that
actually looks like so here we go
there's one there's two there's three I
do know how to count there is four there
is five there is six there is seven
there is eight there is nine and there
is nine and a half look at that look at
you see what's going on here this is the
amount of sugar that you're putting in
your body through corn when you drink
one of these then we wonder why people
have all these health problems right and
diabetes and all this stuff and I bought
her have you drank water it's not that
bad and again I'm not a health nut I'm
really not I'm down to eat whatever and
drink whatever but we should be somewhat
aware I think when you actually look at
this you know that you would never right
you would never if you were just
sweetening like a glass of water with
lemon or like you would never put this
much sugar in there and because this
stuff is black and I think you can clean
like battery acid with it uh
people do it right so I think there's
something to be said for what is
happening right here that is too much
sugar to put in your body
well actually I'm pretty sure that one
can of coke has more than the allotted
amount of sugar supposed to have in a
day if you have about 2,000 calorie
today it's really really nice coke
people please don't kill me I'm just
trying to keep America healthy that's
all ease up drink some water and forward